once if from many years back could
probably be seen as a foolish error
twice starts to get more than a little
problematical however what are we to
make of the fact Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau has admitted he cannot
even recall how many times he's colored
his face to look like a black man and on
one occasion even sang de O'War the
Banana Boat song while dressed and
colored as a Jamaican this man clearly
has an issue to address the fact it's
the self-styled king of the wokes who
weeps openly on TV about the plight of
Syrian refugees hands them coats as they
arrived in his country and chooses to
refer to people kind rather than mankind
is richly ironic for liberals suddenly
their biggest hero on the so-called
world stage now Barack Obama has little
to distract him from his Gulf is
embroiled in a race storm and they call
Donald Trump a racist you've been
waiting for this all your life I mean
there's so many things that are wrong
about he looks like a complete idiot
straight back here is Canadian PM that
man looks just like I mean how many
kinds of [ __ ] would he look like
and on top of that I think the thing
that is most specific this Justin
Trudeau's father of Pierre Trudeau who
was the man the Prime Minister of Canada
who invented the term multiculturalism
and that's why it's become such a big
deal in Canada and if you listen to one
of the opposition politicians let's
remember this is Canada we were talking
about extreme language earlier on in
Canada this is unbelievably extreme
language he's mad I am deeply troubled
but what this means to Canada that young
kids are gonna see not just one or two
but multiple images of the Prime
Minister mocking their live reality this
is so hurtful to so many Canadians how
do you respond to somebody how do you
how do you look someone in the eye
that's that's marked the live reality
that I've lived but more importantly
that so many Canadians have lived I
think he's got a lot to answer for
yeah I think the truth is Justin Trudeau
basically Roldan ruled himself out of
being an electable it's for sheer idiocy
but I will say this let's not get too
over-the-top about this particular thing
if you are a person of color somebody
wearing blackface to be absolutely Frank
it's kind of what you expect of certain
kinds of people and you're much more
concerned for example in this country
about the fact that if you are somebody
of a Pakistani Muslim background on
average you're going to earn 30% less
than somebody let's say of Chinese
heritage that's what matters
this stuff is good fun but it's not
really where the issue is I want to
bring you in right because many one of
the many political parties you've graced
with your presence over recent months
has the word liberal in its title you
are the nearest I've got to a liberal
now what are you gonna do about this
well I pick up on what Trevor said I
mean you say I mean the Canadians have
got an election coming up you say this
rule so much I mean it's like being a
parent you were only remembered for the
things you don't do by your kids
we can't just judge Justin Trudeau by
this absolute idiocy of 20 years ago
no no educating de deep if I have him
any title did I agree he's it's
ridiculous he's a racist
Lucifer Bush I don't think it makes him
a bad man
or not the right leader for Canada do
you would you prefer to have an outer
night dog whistling racist rather than
somebody who greets immigrants at the
airport in Canada who maybe cries at
this plight of Syrian refugees frankly
you know given the choice I think to
adjust in could be preferable the only
point I'd make Rachel is Justin Trudeau
isn't just anybody
he is the son of the man who invented
multicultural he has grown up from the
time he was in his mother's belly with
the idea that you shouldn't do this kind
of took for him to do this
is actually a positive crazy decision
we're gonna hear from Gregg in a moment
but let's hear from Justin Trudeau I
deeply hurt racialized Canadians and I
am deeply sorry for that I understand
the anger and the frustration of people
who every day face discrimination face
anti black racism face systemic bias
face face unconscious unconscious bias
and systemic discrimination and I
recognize that on a personal level I
deeply hurt and disappointed many people
who consider me to be an ally and for
that I am deeply sorry
Canadian PM Justin Trudeau Greg Dyke if
a white man colours his face does it
make him a racist well it depends when
why how all sorts of things regularly
but my view is that I've long believed
that people shouldn't be held to account
for what they did twenty or thirty years
ago in their youth I mean I've never
gone to a fancy dress party dressed as
Gary Glitter thankfully did not know I
didn't know he didn't he didn't know
that's what he's saying
I think his apology was quite true
though didn't it no no no no no he knew
but it was a game he would be winched he
should have known white actor xx play a
fellow yes would you say now that they
can't be on stage why is that it's
Laurence Olivier black tap to plan it's
not at all the same thing it sees doing
that it's basically a conscious insult
and for him of all people in the whole
world to do this we're going to be a
Jamaican and seeing the Banana Boat song
what do you appreciate that the ice on
which I am currently skating is very
thin but
do feel like I'm gonna get myself into
trouble and I don't intend to but I just
I don't know if we're just getting a
little bit over the top because this is
a situation where it was a fancy-dress
situation now I I am there like a rat of
a drainpipe when it comes to fancy dress
situations I love fancy dress I do there
will be many a situation where I've
dressed up to look like somebody that is
not me and I will wear wigs and I will
wear outfits I've even been known on
occasion to try and change my accent
which has never ended well fancy dress
is I'm not insulting someone or being
whatever I'm trying to look like
somebody and if he is it and what was it
in the world who looked like that that
is straightforward caricature [ __ ] I
feel anxious about saying what I feel
when it comes to racism
most people are fundamentally not racist
most people are fundamentally decent
people but I do feel like there is a
culture where if you say the wrong thing
or you you're frightened completely with
you my point is simply that this
particular individual it's not you know
he's not a random person I mean I
couldn't care less what people do but
this particular guy really has done
something which he must know he's in his
late 20s he's already thinking of a
political career and he does it so many
times he cannot remain there as opposed
to ostracizing because actually and I
saw a very very interesting online
debate about this from someone who was
asking the question
he used to go but you know I